.
I'M SURE WE WILL HAVE YOU BACK
BEFORE THEN.
THANK YOU, DAVID.
BRING IT ON.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> IMPORTANTLY, SHE SAYS, THERE
IS NO SCIENTIFIC DEBATE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BIG PICTURE.
>> THERE IS NO ARGUMENT ABOUT
THE VALUE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE.
THERE IS NO ARGUMENT.
>> FORGET HER BEING A POLITICAL
LIABILITY TO THE DEMOCRATS.
RACHEL LEVINE IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST A LAWYER.
THERE IS NO ARGUMENT AMONG
MEDICAL AFFECTIONAL'S ABOUT
SUBJECTING MINORS TO THIS
COMPLETE BARBARITY?
THAT'S FALSE.
>> TRANSITION OF FORMING
THERAPIES ARE VIRTUALLY UNTESTED
AND INFLICT LASTING HARMS.
AND INSTEAD OF PROVIDING PARENTS
WITH MEDICAL INFORMATION AND
EVIDENCE BASED STUDIES, ARE
FREQUENTLY PRESSURED INTO
ACCEPTING THESE RISKY TREATMENTS
ON BEHALF OF THEIR CHILDREN.
>> MEDICATIONS ARE BEING USED
OFF LABEL WITHOUT PROPER FDA
RISK ASSESSMENT PROFILE.
THIS WHOLE THING IS AN
EXPERIMENT ON CHILDREN.
>> LET'S DROP THE MISLEADING
EUPHEMISMS.
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE GOES
BEYOND BOYS WEARING DRESSES AND
GIRLS CHANGING THEIR NAMES.
IT CAN INCLUDE BARBARIC SURGERY
TO REMOVE REPRODUCTIVE ORGANS
AND HORMONES TO BLOCK PUBERTY.
GO UNDER AFFIRMING CARE INCLUDES
SOCIAL AFFIRMATION AT ANY AGE,
PUBERTY BLOCKERS DURING PUBERTY,
AND HORMONE THERAPY STARTING
DURING EARLY ADOLESCENCE.
IRREVERSIBLE SURGERY IS
"TYPICALLY USED IN ADULTHOOD OR
CASE-BY-CASE.
OR A CASE-BY-CASE IN
ADOLESCENTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I SAY?
WHAT IS A CASE BY CASE BASIS?
AT WHAT BASIS ARE THESE MADE FOR
THE ADOLESCENTS TO GET THE
SURGERY?
AND I'M GOING TO GUESS.
IT IS A TOTALITY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
MEANING THE LANGUAGE IS BAD
ENOUGH TO ALLOW FOR GENDER
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY ON DEMAND,
REGARDLESS OF THE AGE.
PARENTS ACROSS AMERICA ARE
SHOCKED AT THE SPEED THAT BASIC
TRUTHS, INSTITUTIONS ARE COMING
UNDER ASSAULT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING THAT THE COURT
TONIGHT.
WHEN THEY SEE A BIOLOGICAL BOY
PLAYING WOMEN OR GIRLS IN A
SPORT, MOST PARENTS ARE
HORRIFIED, THEY ARE OUTRAGED.
THE SAME WAY THAT THEY FEEL WHEN
THEY SEE SCHOOLS MACHINE AND
GENDER IDENTITY DISCUSSIONS ON
LITTLE KIDS.
>> MY ABILITY TO PARENT MY
CHILD.
EVEN BEFORE I HAD ANY KNOWLEDGE,
I DIDN'T EVEN GET TO SHOW
SUPPORT.
YOU ASKED FOR SUPPORT, I DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE.
YOUR JOB WAS TO EDUCATE MY CHILD
AND MATH, SCIENCE, ET CETERA.
DO YOUR JOB, AND LET ME DO MINE.
>> Laura: PHENOMENAL CONCEPT,
DOING YOUR JOB.
CRATERING AMONG ALMOST EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP, THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO FIGHT BACK.
SAW A LITTLE BIT OF THOUGHT ON
THE COURT.
THEY HAVE CONVINCED THEMSELVES
THAT FORCING THEIR IDEAS ON THE
NATION, NO MATTER WHAT THEY HAVE
TO DO TO DO THAT, WILL
ULTIMATELY PAY OFF.
IN THE MEANTIME, THEY TELL
EVERYBODY ELSE AS OUTLIERS,
HOLDING BACK WHAT IS THE
PROGRESS.
AS WE LEARNED OF MOST POLITICAL
PIECE, THE COURT HAS VOTED,
APPARENTLY, TO STRIKE DOWN
ROE V. WADE.
COMING FROM THE SLEEK DRAFT OF
AN OPINION FROM THE COURT WHICH
AGAIN IS A BREACH THAT HAS NEVER
OCCURRED IN THE HISTORY OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
AND BY THE WAY, THE RULING IS
MERELY TO SEND THE ABORTION
ISSUE BACK TO THE STATES.
THE IDEA THAT THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION EVER PROHIBITED
STATES FROM REGULATING OR EVEN
OUTLAWING THE PROCEDURE WAS
TOTAL LEGAL FANTASY FROM DAY
ONE.
IT WAS TOTALLY MADE UP.
THE LEFT IS GOING INTO THE
STRATOSPHERE TONIGHT, THEY ARE
GOING NUTS.
THEY KNOW THEIR ENTIRE FACADE,
EVERYTHING THEY FOUGHT FOR, THIS
IS THE HEEL THEY WILL DIE ON.
THEY ARE WORRIED IT WILL ALL
COME CRUMBLING DOWN.
THEY THINK THAT SOMEHOW THIS
LEAK IS GOING TO BE A GIFT THAT
COULD RESCUE THEM FROM THE
MIDTERM.
WHILE IT IS MISGUIDED.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SAYING ABOUT SOME OF
THE OTHER HOT TOPICS OUT THERE.
GENDER IDENTITY, PUSHING
EDUCATION THE SO-CALLED
ANTIRACISM IDEOLOGY AND CRT
INFLUENCE AND SCHOOLS.
HOW ABOUT THE DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION, MY FAVORITE ACRONYM.
THE ORTHODOXY AND COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS, AND CORPORATE
AMERICA, THE ATTACKS ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE ABORTION
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX THAT IS
SCREAMING OUT TONIGHT.
TRANS ATHLETES AND WOMEN IN
SPORTS.
>> MY 5-YEAR-OLD IS BEING
PEDDLED TRANSGENDER BOOKS IN HER
LIBRARY.
TEENAGERS ARE BEING SERVED UNDER
THE GUISE OF YOUNG ADULT
LITERATURE.
DO SOMETHING, BE A LEADER.
BECAUSE IF YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTY
DESERVE BETTER.
>> AS WE SAW IN ORLANDO,
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS LIKE
RON DeSANTIS ARE FIGHTING BACK
WITH SUCCESS.
EVEN TO GET SOME BIG
CORPORATIONS.
>> THE COMPANY HAS POSTED ITSELF
TO ATTACKING THE PARENTS AND MY
STATE.
WHEN THAT COMPANY [CHEERS AND
APPLAUSE]
>> WHEN THAT COMPANY HAS VERY
HIGH UP PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
THIS IN PROGRAMMING WITH YOUNG
KIDS.
IT IS WRONG.
WALT DISNEY WOULD NOT WANT THAT.
GET BACK TO THE MISSION.
DO WHAT YOU DID GREAT.
THAT IS WHY PEOPLE LOVE THE
COMPANY.
AND YOU LOST YOUR WAY.
MAYBE THIS WILL BE THE WAKE-UP
CALL THAT THEY NEED TO GET BACK
ON TRACK.
>> NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO SEE
THAT RECORDED.
THAT WAS PRETTY WILD.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY ARE
FRESH OUT OF IDEAS.
SO WHAT THEY DECIDED TO DO WAS
WIND UP OLD BIDEN AND SEND HIM
OUT THE SNAPBACK.
>> THERE'S TOO MANY POLITICIANS
TRYING TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS, TRYING TO BAN BOOKS.
DID YOU EVER THINK ANY OF THE
YOUNGER -- DID YOU EVER THINK
YOU WOULD BE WORRYING ABOUT BOOK
BURNINGS AND BANNING BOOKS?
ALL BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT
SOMEBODY'S POLITICAL AGENDA.
WE HAVE TO STOP MAKING OF THE
TARGET OF CULTURE WARS.
>> MAYBE HE WAS SLEEPING OVER
THE PAST 40 YEARS, BUT HIS
LOYALISTS SUCCEEDED IN REMOVING
SOME OF AMERICA'S CLASSIC
LITERARY WORKS OVER THAT TIME.
BOOKS LIKE HUCKLEBERRY FINN, OF
MICE AND MEN, TO KILL A
MOCKINGBIRD.
THOSE ARE BEING TAKEN OUT OF
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
STEVE GOT THE TEACHERS UNION,
THEY ARE FIGHTING NOT FOR GREAT
LITERATURE, BUT AGAIN FOR ANY
MEMORY OF AMERICAN
TRADITIONALISM.
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS -- THAT IS THE GO-TO
CASH COW.
BY THE WAY, MEMBER, THEY DID
MORE DAMAGE TO CHILDREN BY
SUPPORTING THE COVID LOCKDOWNS
THAN WE ARE EVER GOING TO KNOW.
THEY COULD HAVE REMAINED
VIRTUALLY FOREVER, I THINK THEY
WOULD HAVE.
>> IF THERE ARE PROBLEMS AND
SHORTAGES, THEN EITHER SOME
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSING IN THOSE
DISTRICTS WHERE THOSE DISTRICTS
ARE TAKING A PAUSE.
>> IT IS NOT A MATTER OF WE
DON'T WANT TO BE THERE.
IT'S THAT WE CAN'T STAY THERE.
MATH, VACCINATIONS, PROPER
VENTILATION.
OUR SCHOOLS, MOST OF THEM, DON'T
HAVE THOSE BASIC THINGS.
>> STILL WAITING FOR THAT
VENTILATION.
OVER THE WEEKEND, WE WERE IN
FLORIDA, AND OTHER PARTS, WHICH
WE WILL TALK ABOUT LATER, BUT
MOTHERS, FATHERS, THEY WERE
COMING UP TO A SANE, NEVER STOP
FIGHTING FOR US, PLEASE.
IT'S ALWAYS GRATIFYING TO HEAR
FROM YOU.
I HAD NO IDEA HOW BAD THINGS HAD
GOTTEN WITH SCHOOLS UNTIL COVID.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS JUST
DOUBLING DOWN ON THEIR FAILURE
ON ALL THESE CULTURAL ISSUES.
THIS MEANS DEMOCRATS ARE
STANDING AGAINST MORE
TRADITIONAL PARENTS, COMMON
SENSE PARENTS AT THIS POINT WHO
JUST WANT POLITICS OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM.
BUT DEMOCRATS -- THEY ARE
FINDING SOME NEW STARS OUT
THERE.
>> WHO AM I?
I AM A STRAIGHT, WHITE,
CHRISTIAN, SUBURBAN, MARRIED MOM
WHO KNOWS THAT THE VERY NOTION
THAT LEARNING ABOUT SLAVERY OR
REDLINING OR SYSTEMIC RACISM
SOMEHOW MEANS THAT CHILDREN ARE
BEING TAUGHT TO FEEL BAD OR
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY ARE
WHITE IS ABSOLUTE NONSENSE.
I WANT EVERY CHILD IN THE STATE
TO FEEL SEEN, HEARD, AND
SUPPORTED.
NOT MARGINALIZED AND TARGETED
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT STRAIGHT,
WHITE, AND CHRISTIAN.
>> THE NEW YORKER'S CALLING HER
A ROLE MODEL FOR THE MIDTERMS.
I KID YOU NOT.
MOVE OVER, AOC.
A LIBERAL KAREN WITH A HEADBAND
IS COMING FOR THE SPOTLIGHT.
SHE'S PART JOY REID PART JOY'S
SAKE.
IF DEMOCRATS DON'T STAND UP AND
FIGHT BACK ON THE REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO PUT FORWARD PEOPLE
WHO MAY NOT SUPPORT OUR HAVING
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS EVER
AGAIN.
SHE HASN'T HEARD ABOUT THE COURT
YET.
LIBERALS ONE MINUTE -- THAN THEY
SUPPORT LIMITING FREE SPEECH THE
NEXT AND LEAKING STUFF FROM THE
COURT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE THE
ANTI-DEMOCRATS.
AND THEY'RE THINKING IS AS FLAT
AS THEIR SINGING.
MISINFORMATION HERSELF, SHE IS A
RANKED PARTISAN COMING YET
SOMEHOW SHE'S PUT IN CHARGE OF
THE DHS DISINFORMATION OFFICE.
THOSE WHO QUESTION THE HANDLING
OF COVID WERE THE ONES PUSHING
UP THE DISINFORMATION ACCORDING
TO HER.
THE WHOLE WET MARKET ORIGIN
SERIES THAT WAS RIDICULOUS FROM
THE BEGINNING.
IT TURNS OUT HER COMMENTARY ON
THE ORIGINS TRAPPED CHINA'S
REMARKABLY WELL.
GETTING A LAB LEAK THEORY IS
STILL THE MOST PLAUSIBLE
EXPLANATION.
TIKTOK PRINCESS DOESN'T CARE.
THE DEMOCRATS NEW MILLENNIAL
CULTURE WARRIOR WILL SPEND HER
TIME SCOLDING CONSERVATIVE MEDIA
WITH THE KARAOKE ACCOMPANIMENT.
SO WILL ANY OF THIS WORK?
THIS IN-YOUR-FACE DEFENSE THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO HIDE FROM
TAXPAYERS FROM ALL THESE YEARS
BEAR THESE ATTACKS ON THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, EVEN NOW THE
SUPER COURTS LEGITIMATE SEE.
I WILL SAY IS THAT REPUBLICAN
CAMPAIGN MANAGERS AND THEIR
CANDIDATES ACROSS AMERICA
TONIGHT ARE THRILLED ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS NEW STRATEGY.
SO BRING IT ON.
FOR TOO LONG THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT HAS RAN FROM THE
CULTURAL ISSUES OF THE DAY.
LIKE ECONOMIC AND TAX POLICY.
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH.
NOT WITHOUT THE ISSUES THAT
TOUCH THE FORMATION OF OUR
CHILDREN, OUR OWN HEARTS, THE
SANCTITY OF THEIR BODIES AND THE
SAFETY OF OUR STREETS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE REMINDED US
JUST HOW CRITICAL THESE ISSUES
ARE.